-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
Today is National Pasta Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
National Pasta Day.
And this week is Disney's
100-year anniversary.
So in honor of that, I thought
we'd play a brand-new game.
It's time for
"Can You Lady and the Tramp
This Bowl of Pasta?"
-♪ Can You Lady and the Tramp
This Bowl of Pasta? ♪
-Alright.
Now let's meet our two couples.
Come on over, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you.
-Hi!
-Hi. Patricia.
-Arturo.
Where are you guys from?
-Originally from the
Philippines, but I live here.
-Hey!
-Yes. Philippines.
-Philippines. Alright.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Okay. Now, what is your name?
-Marcella.
-Michael.
Where are you guys from?
-Little Neck, Queens.
-Hey! There you go! Alright.
Very good. Welcome.
Here's how the game works.
Each of you has a bowl of pasta
on the table in front of you
that you have to eat with
your hands behind your back.
Once you've both
cleaned your plate,
you'll move on
to the final round,
where each couple
will have to
"Lady and the Tramp
a single strand of pasta
until you're kissing.
Roots, can we --
can we have a little, uh...
Because the first couple
to connect their lips
wins the opportunity to
experience the lights of Venice,
the sounds of Naples,
the aromas of Tuscany...
when they are whisked away
to the enchanting Olive Garden
at Times Square on us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo! Whoo!
Yes!
-Alright, players.
On the count of three.
One. Two. Three.
A-mangia.
Okay, there you go.
This is exciting.
Okay. Alright.
This is taking longer than we
think. There's a lot of pasta.
Get in the same bowl.
That's what the dogs...
[ Laughter ]
I think you're good.
Over there...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
We have a winner. Right over
here. Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was close!
Please enjoy a fully funded trip
to the heart of Italy,
conveniently located
in Times Square.
Olive Garden on the corner of
7th Avenue and 47th Street.
Happy Pasta Day.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.